carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
sí
reciban un cordial saludo desde parís
gracias por estar con nosotros en este
nuevo número muy variado de carrusel de
las artes en el que les hablaremos de
arte plástico moda música y de la serie
francesa del momento
el común palais de parís da una mirada a
la situación de las personas mayores a
través de la instalación la espera de la
colombiana diana velásquez
a 50 años de la muerte de coco chanel su
estilo y elegancia siguen marcando la
moda es lo que muestra la primera
retrospectiva en francia- sobre la
diseñadora más conocida de la historia
parís el louvre el collar de una reina y
arsenio lupin uno de los ladrones más
emblemáticos de la literatura francesa
se encuentran en una nueva serie
original de netflix que le está dando la
vuelta al mundo y en nuestra crónica
musical un álbum resueltamente feminista
folk y ibeas vez de la cantante que
habemus quien conversó con nosotros
no lo sé
el common palais de parís hizo un pedido
especial a la artista plástica
colombiana diana velázquez para exponer
en la fachada del monumental edificio
parisino la artista quien vive y trabaja
en madrid respondió con una instalación
que nos invita a reflexionar sobre la
vejez en estos tiempos de pandemia
ah
diez lienzos de gran formato adornan las
columnas del gran palais de parís se
trata de la instalación la tonta la
espera de la colombiana diana velázquez
obra que nació de una reflexión durante
la pandemia cuando se evidenció la
soledad en la que viven muchos ancianos
en el mundo me centre en la gente mayor
porque pienso que bueno como a todos en
la pandemia del confinamiento nos ha
atravesado de alguna forma y yo pienso
que la situación de la gente mayor en
este
año ha sido complicada y han tenido que
esperar muchas veces solos aislados sin
visitas muchos han muerto también hay
que decirlo y
ha puesto sobre la mesa de más un
momento de la vida hacia el que nos
dirigimos todos pero que está poco
visibilizado
los retratos se inspiraron de
fotografías de personas mayores haciendo
filas en comedores sociales
supermercados laboratorios realidades
cotidianas que el artista puso en el
monumento parisino para que no pasen
desapercibidas esto es un lugar
maravilloso no sólo por su tamaño es
bastante importante en la visibilidad
que tiene la obra efectivamente aquí y
si son retratos por eso también es algo
importante es como que ellos han venido
a ponerse aquí delante a decirnos aquí
estoy mirando
y eso también lo hace muy bello porque
pues es la simpleza del dibujo
realizados sobre un material de
publicidad la pieza no busca hacer
publicidad de nada pero sí como
miremos nuestra mirada hacia la
situación de la gente mayor
[Música]
vamos ahora al encuentro de una gran
dama de la alta costura gabrielle chanel
revolucionó la moda femenina y creó
piezas emblemáticas que hoy figuran en
el guardarropa de cualquier mujer en
2021 se conmemoran los 50 años de su
muerte y aunque su imagen se ha visto
ensombrecida por sus presuntos vínculos
con el nazismo también es cierto que fue
una de las grandes diseñadoras de moda
de la historia es lo que pone de relieve
el palais galliera de parís museo que
organizó la primera retrospectiva jamás
realizada sobre gabrielle chanel en
francia para descubrir el sobrio estilo
de gabrielle chanel hay que adentrarse
en la obscuridad y admirar el brillo de
la verdadera elegancia el palais
galliera de parís ha reunido 350 piezas
únicas de la emblemática modista
francesa cuya obsesión fue crear prendas
de una renovada feminidad
la radicalidad de su propuesta siempre
está basada en esta idea del confort de
la libertad de movimiento de la
simplicidad de la línea a una técnica
muy precisa ella tenía una manera muy
radical de integrar esta noción de
comodidad cosa que era inédita en la
moda y en la alta costura hasta los años
10 quiero decir que esto no era un
criterio que importada en moda femenina
[Música]
son prendas que se adaptan perfectamente
al cuerpo de quien lo lleva y que
garantizan pues una total libertad de
movimiento para ella era tan importante
como ser chic era mostrarse como una
misma y eso es imposible si una misma
está encapsulada o encorsetada en un
vestido
durante más de 60 años coco chanel jugó
con lo masculino en moda femenina
revolucionó con su famoso vestidito
negro y el taller o blazer además creó
el perfume más conocido del mundo su
icónico número 5 y diseño vistosos
accesorios creaciones que todavía hoy
son una referencia en el mundo de la
moda lo que hacía de manera magistral
para combinar conceptos o materiales o
ideas que podrían parecer en un primer
momento contradictorias pero que ella
hace que funcionen de manera pues muy
armoniosa juntas utilizo el punto cuando
el punto es otro se utilizaba para ropa
interior en los años 10 cuando cuando
adoptó bueno pues no sólo materiales y
no sólo prendas del guardarropa
masculino sino incluso actitudes que
hasta entonces estaban reservadas era un
privilegio de los hombres por ejemplo el
hecho de mostrarse
relajado en público
esto era algo que sólo los hombres
hacían la utilización de los bolsillos
una cosa que ahora nos parece tan
evidente no es recurrente constante en
su creación
50 años después de su muerte que queda
diseño en la moda
yo creo que queda casi todo de carrer
sant ahí radica la fuerza de su trabajo
es en la modernidad la atemporalidad de
su estilo es lo que le hace como no ser
todavía hoy una de las grandes
diseñadoras del siglo 20 y por lo tanto
de la historia de la moda y una serie
francesa está teniendo un éxito rotundo
no sólo en francia sino también en el
resto del mundo
lipman en la miniserie de netflix relata
las aventuras de un ladrón de guante
blanco y piel oscura personificado por
la estrella francesa o maxi melisa barra
nos tiene los detalles
su coche
es el único
mariposa y no es curioso sea
en la pantalla el carismático maxi
encarna a sanyo un versátil ladrón y
maestro en prestidigitación quien usa
sus talentos para robar un collar
invaluable en el museo del lujo el
astuto asan hijo de inmigrantes
senegaleses e inspira del señor para el
sherlock holmes francés un personaje de
la literatura de detectives creado por
móvil o blog que ha divertido a
generaciones de lectores desde
principios del siglo 20
arsenio ya sanz ambos comparten una
visión del robo lo hacen con gran
elegancia y por causas justas en la
serie asan busca vengar la muerte de su
padre acusado injustamente por el robo
del collar
la historia se desarrolla en el parís
actual con el trasfondo de desigualdad
social y racismo que se extienden desde
los barrios populares hasta las esferas
más adineradas
louis pana recuerda las cintas de
famosos atracos de hollywood pero
también hace referencia a grandes
novelas de cappa
como el conde de montecristo o la
pimpinela escarlata
tener que llevar a tu locura
también está chicane
robos acción y un intrépido y estudio
ladrón la fórmula ha fascinado los
televidentes del mundo entero en tan
sólo una semana el 'ipad' se alzó en el
ranking de las 10 series más vistas de
netflix en países como francia eeuu
colombia o méxico
[Música]
y pasamos ahora a nuestro segmento
musical y para eso ya tenemos en el
estudio a natalia olivares hola natalia
y hoy vamos a recorrer nuevamente las
calles de parís y esta vez maría
carolina fuimos al distrito 12 de la
capital y nos encontramos con un artista
llena de colores
[Música]
hola a todo le propongo descubrir una
música para dar un golpe de energía y lo
necesitamos que haremos es una artista
hecha y fabricada en francia su música
habla de cual es importante recordar sus
orígenes con es importante criticar la
sociedad y decir lo que uno piensa y eso
es energía positiva muchas gracias
'queremos por estar con nosotros muchas
gracias
sexo la pongo a 77 puntos a 1 pues que
existe esta canción es ante todo una
respuesta al sexismo al machismo y a la
violencia contra las mujeres
yo quería mandar un mensaje positivo de
solidaridad femenina de hermandad me
conmueve profundamente escuchar a muchas
mujeres que me dicen que ese mensaje les
hace fuertes les da ahora existe ese
positivismo de decir que juntas somos
más fuertes la lucha comenzó hace mucho
tiempo pero no ha terminado y seremos
cada vez más cuerpo como maine para
termine el raid de fútbol fifa
[Música]
qué haremos nos habla de su canción las
tres princesas que forman parte de su
nuevo álbum live for live vea en
referencia al gran cabaret
oliverio es el nombre del gran y mítico
cabaret parisino y encontré que el
nombre de bolivia
pues se hacía muy juego de palabras para
hablar de lo que es francia actualmente
es decir una francia multicultural con
todas sus riquezas también se refiere a
mi origen francés y weisberg o bereber y
es un hombre que va bien con mi carrera
como diseñadora de vestuario o cabaret
es la música el baile etcétera resume
bien mi carrera me sigla no si estás
estresado se tenían bajo apoyarles
[Música]
qué haremos si 'apocalypse now' un
título también de su álbum live oliver
ver ya la pregunta es necesario hablar
de sus raíces respondió eso me tocó a
mis tías me hicieron descubrir el pie y
aún cartoon y es realmente esa mezcla la
que representa quién soy yo es mi
cultura nací en francia soy de origen
bereber o bereber y tengo esta doble
cultura musical y esta culinaria
saludos saludos
américa latino la china
gracias natal olivares por esa
conversación con caray mucho y
justamente vamos a terminar nuestro
carrusel de las artes de hoy con la
música hans es de cara y mucho
muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros cuídense mucho y hasta la
próxima san jorge
bien
[Música]
de poderes